[Music]
tonight is a big night in the sports
world you know that because forget about
the Olympics the 142nd Westminster
Kennel Club will crown a new Best in
Show and the contenders have the doggy
world buzzing he does not like to be
dirty police getting sloth he's calling
to say actually the dogs that win best
Michelle Westminster become a big part
of dogs Shore history and will be talked
about the generations to come
and it all comes down to tonight for
these crimped polished and somewhat
shell-shocked pups and the one to beat
for Best in Show biggy the pug
we were behind the scenes in New York
leading up to the big moment nice smile
and since this is considered the Oscars
of dog shows we asked the handlers who
would be their dog's celebrity
doppelganger
he's so laid-back I think Jimmy Fallon
you know laid-back guy
he could be Peyton Manning cheap shot
he's Joe Perry from Aerosmith
he likes to stand out he's just chill
relaxed and goes with the flow and
everybody really likes you